RUTH OCHS: Sinfonia is a
full-size orchestra here
at the University.
We are usually about
60 members strong.
We invite undergraduates
and also are
inclusive of graduate students.
Allie Lichterman, she's a
violinist, and she came to me
and mentioned this after
school tutoring program
that she volunteers for, and
how many of these middle school
students come with
instruments after school.
And she had the very clever
idea of finding a way
to collaborate with them
to bring some Sinfonia
students over to CHASA--
Community House After School
Academy-- to play with
these middle schoolers,
and thought that we
should give this a try.
ALLIE LICHTERMAN:
One day I was just
here working with some kids.
And Aba, actually,
pulled out her flute
and started playing
Katy Perry on the flute.
And I was like, oh, I didn't
know you guys play instruments.
And it turns out a
bunch of them did.
We worked it out
that every Tuesday
for about an hour a group of
us come and we play and talk
about music.
Sometimes we talk
about why we started
playing, what like about it.
We ended up being able to
play at Communiversity,
which was awesome.
And that was a great
goal to work towards.
And now that we're past that,
we're still hanging out,
playing music.
RAINA WILLIAMSON: I like being
able to play different things,
like things that
are challenging,
and learning new things
about my instrument.
ABA SMITH: So, playing with a
bunch of college students.
It makes me really happy.
Because one, I get to see
what they're doing in college,
so I get an idea of what it's
like for me when I grow up
when I go to college,
to actually get
the feeling of what it's going
to be like for me in college
when I do play on flute.
And it gives me a choice if
I want to stay with flute
or if I want to quit.
And right now, my choice is
I want to stay with flute.
ANDREW SHU: I hope that
by playing with them
they'll also be able to have
a fun time enjoying music
and keep it with them when
they grow up, like I have.
And it's been a major
part of my life.
ABA SMITH: I
actually like it when
we play our
instruments together.
When we all play the same
note, I can actually feel it.
And it's sort of like we're
our own little family together,
playing instruments.